one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the
nowar
me thank you so much that made me feel
[Music]
for Gary Gary Gary
hello hello it's the end it's the end of
2023 what What shirt are you wearing oh
look at me this is my favorite it's hard
to pick a favorite but she is my
ambitious angel I have her not only in a
t-shirt but I have the the kids version
which by the way works for an adult you
get the
2XL white sweatshirt highly recommend
very soft Let's uh let's give a big
shout out to everybody tuning in I see
YouTube representing Kevin Jordan good
to see you Last of a Dying seed TV I see
you I see LinkedIn coming in Oscar
Hernandez Christina e coming in uh I see
I see that it's live on Twitter and
Facebook as well so we'll see if those
come in here in the chat but I see
Michael F big shout out I also have
twitch live on mute here amazing we can
unmute them actually um cool let's rock
and roll we got today we got lucky seven
speakers today and we're going to be
talking about 2024 what's in store and
first up I'm going to have you gu yes
Gary who this is it's kind of a it's a
it's a sizable bio if you will so this
dude is successful serial entrepreneur
Who Sold I think it's Jesse ller oh rats
you got it already he's an ultra this
guy's insane but positively insane he's
an ultramarathon Runner who's biked
across the country he's founder of all
day running he's got four kids he's a
former rapper who managed Run DMC oh my
gosh he's he's married to Sarah Blakeley
and most importantly maybe at least for
right now is he is the creator of the
big ass calendar club I'm hoping we hear
a little bit more about
that Jesse how are you my man Gary you
got a green pen I got a green pen we are
so in sync my dude we are so
locked in right now unscripted we're
both green pen guys I you know what I've
always known that we were locked in but
this might have been the final
cherry on top
I love it I got to get you an all day
running cap and then we're really locked
in I'll rock it my friend Jess for the
four people that don't know who you are
give us one half second on that and
let's go and chop up what's in store for
24 yeah I've had an unconventional
business Journey um I started out as in
the music business as as mentioned as a
rapper then I had a private jet company
called Marquee jet sold it to Warren
Buffett's netjets a coconut water
company called ziko sold it to
Coca-Cola um a fitness company sold it
to fit I've had five exits and I'm a dad
of four um yeah that's me actually real
quick on that for people that are going
into 2024 thinking about selling their
company as someone who's had the
experience of five exits which is
remarkable um what's the biggest lesson
you've learned across all five of those
like what's the common theme what's a
watch out as as the people that are on
here that are either fortunate enough to
be setting up an exit that they're
excited about or maybe even more
concerning and maybe you can speak to
this maybe some of the five you had was
a little bit you know I'm going to
assume Jess with five exits some were a
little bit more frontf footed than backf
footed right like sometimes you're
selling because just like the demand is
there and you're just getting a huge
multiple other times you're like man
even if the company's fine if you you or
the management team don't have the fire
anymore or you see the Tailwinds like
give us a little wisdom on being on your
front or back foot as you go into 2024
pondering an exit of your business well
the first thing I would say say is that
none of the businesses that I sold I had
any experience in going into it I had no
prior experience in aviation music
coconut what and for a lot of people
entrepreneurs on this call that could be
a great concern but for me it was a
blessing because it guaranteed that my
products my companies my services would
be different than all my competition so
for many people that's a gift not having
experience because it means you're going
to do things differently I always say
like if no one taught you how to do your
job like how would you do it that's
always been the biggest strength of my
career I call it fresh eyes like my
whole career the wine business the the
advertis I mean I knew nothing about
advertising when I started Vayner media
I think fresh eyes if you're a capable
operator are dangerous eyes AKA give you
actually an advantage because you see
that the people that are incumbents
can't see yeah I would say the second
thing theme for me is like in all those
businesses even though they were so
different like the common theme was I
poured my soul into it and people feel
Soul you can't Outsource it you can't
fake it and there was this incredible
passion behind all of that any goal I
emptied the tank and poured my soul into
it as far as selling the companies you
know for me I had no experience in that
my dad owned the plumbing supply house I
never we never sold companies in my
family I fortunate to realize that
that's not my skill set and find you
know Brokers companies um that could
help me lawyers that could assist me in
that Journey so knowing weakness going
to 2024 and when you're in a position
aess to higher your weakness you do it
yeah actually real quick I just want to
give a quick shout out Sherry woodstein
said uh clean up your mouth on LinkedIn
clean up your mouth you shouldn't be
using the one word You' said a few
minutes ago I uh I'm leaving this and
we'll never go to any other your lives
that you might do Sher I just want to
apologize um I'm I'm incapable of not
being myself and I apologize that the
cursing didn't hit but I wish you the
best best um holiday and I think back to
your point about like self-awareness I
also think humility going into 2024 I'm
incredibly empathetic for Sherry's
comment right now on LinkedIn some
people are not comfortable with cursing
the way maybe I am and I don't VI that
as she doesn't get it or she's from you
know the old school I actually think you
bring up a beautiful thing of like
self-awareness of what you're not good
at I also think a big thing that people
can really build on is I think humility
is lacking I think when people see the
world differently we get very
confrontational I wasn't being
condescending or or silly just now I'm
actually genuinely apologetic to Sherry
I I I want to stay my way I feel
comfortable in my authenticity but that
doesn't give me the inability to have
the humility to apologize if somebody
randomly popped up on LinkedIn and saw
this and didn't enjoy it and I think we
need more of that as well and I think
self-awareness and humility work very
nicely together thoughts on that Jess
well I mean you come to a Gary ve thing
you know it's going to be PG-13 or R
yeah and and by the way she might not
you know it seems like she was here for
the first time and and didn't know what
she you know that I might have a little
bit more of a potty mouth and so I just
want to do that anyway Jess this big ass
calendar I I saw Zach walking around
with it actually why don't you tell
everybody I see it I'm gonna go grab
actually just if you don't mind that big
ass calendar Jess what is this thing I'm
a big planner so we're talking about
what's in store for
2024 and yeah so Gary check this out I
have mine here too by the way good job
taking out the SS here I don't want
anyone to leave I don't want anyone to
leave want to lose anybody in the chat
Jess I lose people here man I don't want
to lose PE people here I appreciate you
bringing that up and you know as we talk
about 2024 before I even go there Gary
my word for 2024 like this is a great
time December right now to prepare for
next year and it's I think it's really
important for everybody here I'll
explain that in a second Gary to go into
2024 light go in as light as you can and
for me I use this time right now to
clear my desks delete my emails clean
out my closet like I want to declutter
and feel light going into 202 I love
that I'm a fan I don't wantan to go in
heavy I don't want to go in heavy I want
to get as light as I can right this is
this is why gratitude is my word for 24
you're doing it right physically and I
believe in the minimalism the Simplicity
I want people to go like emot
why not be grateful for what you have
instead of all the energy that
everyone's putting into what they don't
have right right and so for me that's
really important I want to come into the
year fresh but you know you mentioned
the calendar I'll plug it real quick
this is my entire 2024 already planned
my Year is already Bak this is all my
trips speeches date nights like I feel
like I'm 55 Gary I'm 55 and I feel like
as you get old they creating newness is
really hard like where does newness come
from man we live in routine so I feel
like if we don't plan it usually it
won't happen and I'm really aggressive
with my planning because if I don't
prioritize me my calendar fills up with
work Zoom calls and stuff that I don't
even at the end of the year like it
doesn't mean anything to me so I try to
plan my life and and in 2024 before all
my meetings and stuff and let as much
work's always going to fill in it's
always happening but I put the important
stuff that I want to do so at the end of
2024 I'm going to the end of 2024 now
that I have stuff that I can show for it
you know I want to be able at the end of
2023 what did you do what did you
accomplish what did you you worked your
ass off don't leave me for saying the
word ass you worked your ass off but
what do you have to show for it in the
365 days and there's an old Japanese
ritual called the misogi and the notion
around the misogi is you do one big year
defining thing every year so it's really
important like if you could look back
this is for everybody and say like if I
ask what' you do in 2015 2017 2019 you
should be able to rat rattle off oh I
launched a book in 20 2015 2023 I rolled
my bike Across America and that one
thing of having a big year defining
thing to me is critical because if Gary
if you live another 30 40 years you know
what do you got 112 120 in you I'm 48
I'm going for at least 100 I feel like
I'm got 52 and like I feel like I'm
starting to maybe look at going into
halftime but I have like real things to
do here brother you might have 60 in you
I agree 30 40 I'd be pissed by the way
if I pass within 30 40 when I get up
there the first thing I'm gonna say is
like yo Jesse ller he was the one
that this up I didn't even mean
to put it in the universe but you're
defending it so much God I appreciate it
when when you go at the endend of your
journey Gary what do you what are people
gonna say about you what do you want
people to say about you that I gave more
than I
took have you always been like that yeah
long before anybody knew who the hell I
was like I wish some Junior higher high
school friends are in the chat right now
and be like he said that before
there was the internet I've always been
I I had the alltime mother and the
alltime circumstance of immigrant life
and humility and happiness and it just
like it was over before it started you
know like I just got very fortunate
my you know somebody said in the chat
just now Gary you know you have
Christian very heavy Christian values
what do you think about that I think
that I said what do I think about that I
think that makes sense I'm very aware
that my stuff is old school you know
yeah I'm old school like I'm a modern
dude I do new technology and all this
I'm hyper I can curse I get all that but
man in my soul boy do I like people do
you take a lot of time planning for the
upcoming
year I you know what's funny I do you
have a process yeah I have a whole I
mean I know my entire yes I have a
process it's called a team we like I
have like a meeting in my like this is
literally at 12:30 on my schedule I'm
going to review the next week two weeks
like I'm in it because of the way I roll
but I'm also a big buyer of your macro
thesis of like big things like I I
during my holidays I basically give one
thoughtful thing of like what
relationships or what impact do I want
to have on the year Jess listen I need
to get you on podcast with friends or a
solo podcast because we have too much to
talk about I'm already three minutes
late I have to abruptly kick you out
because everyone's yelling at me behind
the scenes I love you I love your
calendar I love your family I love the
way you roll I love the way you impact I
wish you nothing but health and
happiness brother I can't wait till we
we have lunch and dinner together 65
years from now Gary I'll be 127 there we
go brother I love you see you all
right such fire all right next up we got
Jason Ang grasani great great friend of
ours who is the chief marketing and
Communications officer at caner
Fitzgerald and he came from Bloomberg
and we were just talking Gary a little
bit about um Jason's been playing some
soccer with his kids you might want to
ask him a little bit about that too I
love that how are you brother good man
how are you I was really enjoying the
conversation with Jesse I could have
tuned into that all day Jayce I
appreciate that brother let's go right
into it let's go in a different
direction let's like we kind of went
spiritually there I like the whole ying
and yang stuff talk to me about the
business World obviously sitting on top
of such a a premier business entity you
know there's a lot that I feel in the
air of uncertainty going into 2024 an
election year people are emotionally on
tilt in America and globally there's
some other big elections around the
world so that's in the a um you know
interest rates you're hearing momentum
of like coming down you know they've
been High um every company I talk to is
struggling with the remote working
environment almost every business is
feeling the effects of less productivity
in this environment and that kind of
starting to hit the fan I mean I had I
literally had a CEO of a major company
cry to me that she's going to have to
let go of a lot of people because in
hindsight she didn't make the workforce
come back to the office enough and the
business can't sustain and she thought
she was doing the right thing and now
she's got the and it hit me hard because
that's what I'm going through think
about my universe so there's a lot in
the air what's in store from 2024 from
your perspective on these big macro
business Trends well let's start let's
start with people because I think in
2024 we have to start investing back in
people there was huge hiring Trends in
2020 and 2021 inflating the workforce
Focus engagement focusing on remote
engagement and that was all well and
good but then you're seeing over the
last year a lot of layoffs happening
Rifts happening there's just a lot of
people freaking out about what's in
store for them going forward and even
for me personally I left a great role at
Bloomberg was there for 13 years to take
on on a brand new challenge here at
caner with a smaller team a bigger scope
and a whole lot of other things to worry
about but the F the thing I always go
back to is if you can surround yourself
with really good people and Empower
those people to make decisions and
really bring them along on your journey
for planning and success you're going to
be successful so that's what I'm I'm
always focused on how do I get people on
the same page believing that they're
contributing to what we're trying to do
as an organization going forward not
just having it be me dictating the
direction and and bringing the leaders
along so they can bring other folks
along and and we start to build a sense
of camaraderie and togetherness then
that leads to people wanting to come
into the office wanting to together
because listen like we we could argue
all day long about productivity levels
during the pandemic yeah people were
more productive but they didn't connect
they didn't
collaborate page and in order for you to
feel like this isn't just a job that
you're showing up to every day and
commuting x amount of time my commutes
three hours a day uh to and from work
right but I do it because I want to
connect with people I want to hear their
ideas I want to collaborate on problems
that we have I want to commiserate on
how miserable the commute was and all
that stuff but focusing on how do we
make them better at their jobs better
colleagues better people better parents
better brothers and sisters and and and
um you know that's what I really focus
on I people to me is everything yeah
there is nothing else how do you think
everything gets done I'm with you I
think the other thing is that a lot of
business owners don't realize that
people have options even if look I think
I think we'll see a continuation of lack
of hiring because like businesses do
business things like they're going to
they're going to have to let go of
people before they miss Bank covenants
and don't have a credit line and then
fully go out of business and all 800
people have to like it's just real life
right like like you know like I see it
in small business like people are going
to you know even if have they tend like
it's just businesses are going to do
business business things but humans have
more options than ever the the side
hustles are becoming real businesses and
so there's a there's when I think about
start stop continue you know start
trying to build something for yourself
that doesn't make you vulnerable to the
business stop being just concerned and
fear-based and start creating that and
then continue the things that are making
you happy because you really have a lot
of control and that's both for the
businesses but more importantly for the
employees you have to be it's confidence
right you as marketers you always hear
the the argument of all right you know
is it a cost center is it a growth
driver I don't even subscribe to that at
the end of the day marketing is not a
back office function right it's not a
support function it's a growth driver
for any organization that wants to be
serious about moving forward and you
know in the B2B land that i' I've lived
in throughout pretty much all of my
career sometimes that's a difficult
conversation to have with CEOs or or
other you know Coos CFOs all the people
that we have to deal with on a daily
basis but it's having the confidence to
be able to tell your story and
articulate what the team is doing
against those business objectives that
that are critical if anybody that's ever
worked with me will say I think will say
one thing which is I'm constantly
focused on results value and impact like
if we're not adding value to what the
business is trying to achieve we
shouldn't be doing it period end of
story right nowadays that conversation's
a little bit different it's more values
based so we're thinking about the
intersection between brand and demand
how do we
instill values throughout the customer
Journey throughout everything that we're
doing trying to connect what the
business is all about and and what the
company's all about to the bottom line
impact and and you know at Bloomberg we
invested a ton in the foundation Mike
invested a ton in his foundation and we
always tried to connect the dots between
what we were doing on a philanthropic
standpoint to what the business what it
what it meant to work with Bloomberg as
an organization at caner it's really no
different you know the resiliency of
this firm post 911 has been tremendous
and connecting those dots to what we're
actually trying to be in the market a
lot of people don't even know what we do
anymore and that's part of the brought
me on and to try to change that
narrative but it's not just about
talking about the the ex's and O's of
the business it's about connecting the
dots with what this firm is what it
means what any firm is what it means to
people how it connects with people
because people want to do business with
brands that they trust period end of
story and if
you how human behaviors always work
whether it's people or businesses always
f thought before we get out of here
brother what a what is a big opportunity
you see for employees employers
businesses side hustles what's up what's
something that's got you kind of jazzed
as opportunity in
24 right it's it's I hate to be cliche
about it but it's you know experiment
with AI try new things out dive into
technology it's it's what we're going to
be facing in the future and you're
either going to be ahead of the game or
you're going to be behind the times and
you you can try a bunch of things fail
but there's so much opportunity out
there to to be experimental do it dive
in and don't be afraid to fail I love it
brother I wish you a happy holiday Jason
you too thanks for the time Gary
appreciate it see you soon take care
bro next up we've got Lyn Tio she's the
CMO of Northwestern Mutual she just
joined over a year ago and she already
won the 2023 Financial marketer of the
Year congratulations Lynn thank you
thank you and big shout out to Jason for
giving me the full
10 Lynn how are things things are
awesome I'm here in sunny Milwaukee
where it's cold uh but you know what you
lean into the people around you and if
they you know bring some light that's
all you need I love it so let's talk
about start stop and continue in 24 if I
give you that framework yeah what do you
think people should stop doing going
into 24 yeah what's your what's your
opinion on things they should start
doing and what's your opinion on things
that people should continue doing Andor
if you want to take it a different angle
as you think about your 2024 what are
you gonna start doing what are you gonna
stop doing and what are you gonna
continue doing all right so let's go for
it I'll start with the stop um so the
first thing I would say to stop doing is
isolated marketing activities stop doing
them stop creating micro sites that
unconnected to the architecture or the
fabric of your your other digital
properties stop creating one of events
that don't have a planful way of
thinking before during and after who are
you sending the in invites to what
actions do you want them some of these
events are expensive events from wine
tasting to Chocolate me hold on hold on
say oh
yes no stopping the wine T tastings Lynn
my dad is my dad is watching this I'm
about to get a text from Sasha saying
who's this Lynn unacceptable no no no
it's not about stopping the wine tasting
is about thinking carefully about what
you're doing after the wine tasting by
the way I'm fully in agreement that in
the marketing World way too much
one-offs with no no cohesion or really
rhy or reedon I mean look I don't mind
things that look potentially as a
one-off if it's trying to win relevance
with a specific consumer segmentation
but I but I but I agree with you I think
there's a little bit too much spray and
prey throw against the wall and see what
sticks exactly and to expand on that a
little further think about your orc
structure as any marketing leader tuning
in right now you know think about where
you're duplicating efforts right I I
found tremendous success in creating
deep specializations within the orc
structure of a marketing team so senses
of Excellence right because you can
borrow that skill set across multiple
places instead of duplicating that
function within every single one of them
so encourage you to look under the
covers so that's my stop let's go to
start I love using acon and I'm just
goingon to make one up on the Fly it's
called The
mfo Funnel Obsession I want to ask all
marketers to take a look at your funnels
funnels are still relevant it just gives
you a framework to think about how your
activities link from one to another what
I'm seeing a lot is investments in top
and bottom of funnel right and I think
the mistake here is letting your CPA
your CPAs your cpls be the thing that
you live and die by I understand that
there are times you want to hit right at
the bottom of the funnel because that's
where intent is high motivation is high
they knowand it's also measurable for a
lot of organizations totally right
because a lot of us are still in the
last touch attribution models which is
why places like Google get extra credit
for other parts of the funnel doing the
work you hear about something in your
Spotify playlist as a pre-roll and then
you grab your phone and you go to Google
and type it in because many people use
Google Google as their browser and then
all of a sudden back home in marketing
land you think Google brought you the
customer when in fact it was your
Spotify ad that's exactly right your
Spotify ad as your first point of touch
but then there was a bunch of other
nurturing activi so I would say um and
then we all know the story and the
constant refrain of spending in on top
of funnel write brand stories but the
question I would ask is where's your
Brand Story going right so what's the
six other touches you need to design for
and bear in mind those touches might be
very different for different segments
different Subs segments so think of your
sales marketers like an architect right
you're building a house you've got the
roof you've got the rooms you've got the
bed that you sleep on right so I would
say mfo midf funnel obsession is what
I'd like you all to think and start
doing in
2024 and then we'll do the last one Gary
we'll do continue and a lot of people
might be surprised hearing me because
you know my my forway into marketing
started in the digital space but I would
say bring traditional back what's old is
new again right and I'm a firm believer
that there's no binary good marketing
tactics bad marketing tactics I I I've
just invested in a sponsorship I've
looked at email marketing differently
and God help us direct mail it is still
relevant guys well it's it's interesting
which ones you chose right you chose
sponsorship which in a lot of ways as an
awareness play I like and I don't know
what are you talking about sports Jersey
you're talking about something else
Sports Jersey we were we just sponsored
the Milwaukee Brewers and that that
decision was made after thoughtful
consideration that I like because people
actually watch the baseball game and
will actually see the impression and the
reinforcement and the awareness right
right direct mail even even though it
doesn't convert the way it did 20 years
ago there's a lot of direct mail
campaigns that the company got the
return that they were looking for on the
investment do I believe perfect pay
attention to the words I'm saying do I
believe perfect Facebook execution
creative and media outperforms direct
mail for the same function I do because
I've tested them both enough over the
last 34 years do I believe though that
it is very possible to make a direct
mail campaign work yes sponsorship yes
what was the third one email yes like
all like you said traditional and what's
interesting is sports jerseys in America
is brand new yeah obviously worked in
Europe for a long time right email as
traditional is kind of enjoyable because
it's still only a 25y year phenomenon
but check respect and direct mail is
probably the most you're missing the
thing here Gary it's a conation email Ed
with Direct Mail that's the magic when
do you time it when do you surround your
target audience with it I think that's
the unlock and then going back to
sponsorships when we came up with the
thinking wasn't just the jersey it was
how it intersects with the community
efforts of both foundations how do you
drive online Demand right how do you
generate how do you activate my field my
field is my growth engine so how do I
bring my field I I think the thing
you're touching on Lynn that I'm such a
buyer of is love old as new I mean all
my content right now is that we need to
respect our elders I think we've put
youth on a pedestal too much and have
completely lost our respect for our
elders exactly that being said there are
people when they hear that statement
that will continue to hold up overpriced
marketing behaviors yeah on an ideology
the things you just mapped out I in on
December 5th 2024 there are multiple
executions that the money is worth the
execution
side if your what's old as new again
tactic is to do Banner ad advertising on
the internet like it did and crushed in
the late 90s and early 2000s I would
argue very heavily against that in
comparison to what social media
platforms give you in the same game at a
much lower cost so I think I think over
you know to the thing that I want to
point out for the people that are
listening is I love that overall
statement but wasting money in any shape
or form and marketing is a bad idea is
never invoked I that's a wonderful
thought rning regular television
commercials on network and cable at the
costs yeah that they are today is
asinine
yeah agreed it's all about connecting
the dots and you know squeezing the best
value out of your investment so there
you have it start stop continue for 24
Lynn I hope you have a very healthy and
happy holiday
you as well Gary thanks for having me
byebye thanks
Lynn Gary next we have the CMO of Xerox
Dena um who has just gone through a big
rebranding hi Dena Hi hi Gary how are
you good Dina why don't you why don't we
actually start with that tell us about
this big rebranding you know obviously
zerox is so iconic I'm sure for a lot
everybody who's watching and listening
in the future there might be some fun C
I about that so let's start there
actually and happy holidays yes thank
you thanks for having me so Xerox is
this iconic brand um you know Legacy and
of innovation and Heritage and really
transforming the workplace but we've got
to reintroduce ourselves we've got to
reintroduce uh ourselves to to new
audiences and we've also got to tell
people about the things that we're doing
now that they don't know that we're
doing right synonymous with copy became
a verb right a Xerox brand became a verb
how do you
disassociate from that thing that made
you a household name and make sure
people know about the new stuff you're
doing so what we did is we launched an
integrated brand and demand gen campaign
something I recommend everybody look at
starting to do in 24 you got limited
resources you really gota you can't
afford to have siloed brand and demand
gen campaigns right so we we launched an
integrated one it's called we make work
work and it's about explaining kind of
what we're doing today the world's
changed the workplace has changed we're
hybrid we're stressed we're distributed
um technology has changed and so a lot
of the services we have today are about
enabling you to be productive in today's
Workforce so how much of a challenge do
you think it is to get people educated
on what's something like a Xerox is up
to now when we all have you know if
we're over 25 it's like we all have a
very specific thing that we're thinking
do you feel like you know from your
perspective that
is a bigger challenge than even being a
brand that no one knows or are they both
kind of similar because they're opposite
sides of the pillow in the middle and is
a little bit easier than a full Rebrand
build I think sometimes it is more
challenging right and you mentioned the
25 and over we actually still got to get
stronger in the 25 to 44 demographic 45
and over were really strong yeah it's
very fair very fa um so it is hard
you've got to reintroduce yourself and
so that's why this year's campaign it
really kind of over indexed on being you
know we use some of our heritage we used
the Bold Xerox red and and got it front
and center in front of people but we put
a modern twist and use really Punchy
witty copy that we've never used before
to Intrigue people into learning more
about what we actually where where Dina
where are you executing that because I
think one of I'm always you know I'm
just to jump been I've been thinking a
lot about the fact that most brands are
stuck in a campaign framework in Big
Brand land and for me my religion is man
if you're not marketing every day you
have no shot which is why I'm obsessed
with social media advertising I think
people grossly underestimate what
day-to-day content and social means um
in the and when you think about such an
iconic brand and when you talk about I
want to win 45 and under when I think
about their consumption of this device
over everything is it a challenge to get
your constituents around the table in
the organization to understand the
needed investment not in digital but in
modern digital because you know this
digital can mean a lot like you know I
was just on with in the last call you
saw she was using digital as like email
as as going back because digital can get
very very traditional and very old
school you know to me do you feel great
about what's going on with Xerox from a
social media day in and day out uh
content or are you doing more of a
matching luggage of the campaign or
where are you on this journey yeah so
first of all You' got to have a mix
right you've got to be multi-channel and
you've got to get into these modern
places so we have a mix and one of the
things I was going to say people need to
stop playing it safe you've got to
you've got to test you've got to fail
you've got to iterate you've got to
optimize based on the data that comes
out of what you're doing like out of
home digital actually overperformed for
us and gave us a lot of value connected
TVs spots I heard you say you'd never
buy cable I we didn't either but we
tried some connected TVs I I I love fast
channels connected TV I mean all of the
modern television channels their
capabilities on the targeting and media
buying look much more like social media
and I think are bring really interesting
dividends I have a lot of passion that
we have to stop making videos that
people don't want to watch this this
phenomenon of making commercials has to
finally hit ahead in our industry these
videos are not things nobody on this
twitch Channel right now nobody in these
streams like they do not want to watch
these boring 30 second videos and you
know this Dina as a senior marketer
they're freaking expensive they super
expensive they got to be relevant
they've got to be like they got to be
emotional they got to be relevant they
got to capture the audience we had 97%
rate of like full completion view in our
connected TV spots because we went
totally different right we we focused on
what do you you know you want to get
home you want to close your laptop you
want to get home in time to read your
kid a bedtime story or get to their
soccer game that's what matters at the
end of the day that's what you want to
see in an ad that pequs your interest so
we know in I'm sorry to interrupt in an
ad like just my big thing that I'm
trying to get all 2,000 people at vayer
media understand let's make videos
people want to watch to your point
there's some people that want to see a
video that inspires an emotional truth
that they want to get home right now
while they're at work and they see it on
LinkedIn and they want to get home on
the flip side there's some people that
just want to see something funny yep
there's PE like but real funny not like
the bad jokes we put in commercials I'm
talking more like SNL like like or a
music video like just a video people
want to
watch yeah we're like we're testing Tik
Tok right like so we had to do that
education internally here and like we
need to get paid Tik Tok ads right right
and think about think about how you said
that we're testing Tik Tok Tik Tok has
dominated for the last five years I know
but not for our brand so exactly where
you got to get legy iconic brand educate
the people and the stakeholders inside
on what's going on outside and where you
need to be to get to the audiences that
you want to reach right I love that Dina
let me ask you a quick question back to
as we go into 24 I want to go backwards
a little bit I I kind of like this
concept of giving people flowers while
they're still alive I feel like we say
all these nice things after people pass
I I think this would be a fun moment you
are the CMO of Xerox you have an iconic
marketing job I'm sure at times the
little you like if you think about it
you're like I'm the CMO of Xerox can we
give some flowers to maybe when you were
a young marketer maybe someone who said
something in a meeting or did something
like if I said a mentor or someone maybe
might not even be your biggest Mentor
but somebody said something in one
meeting and it penetrated your mind and
your soul and your perspective and you
built off of it who can we give some
flowers to um in this in this one onone
that you think were were Maybe
instrumental please yeah the person who
brought me to Xerox actually Mike
Feldman um he brought me in a different
role and he tapped me for this role when
there was the opportunity and he pushed
me to make sure I raised my hand and and
got in the game and he's uh he's an
amazing person and and you know what he
told me he said this is going to be the
best time of your career have fun you're
going to enjoy it and uh and I am I'm
enjoying it I have a great team I love
love that tell me one thing that you
want to continue that you learned in 23
either as Dina the human being or as the
marketer as we we wrap up this interview
like what's some I think I mean it's
both I'm like a super datadriven person
as a marketer and as a leader and so one
of the things I want to continue is
really optimizing based on what the data
is telling us right so we you know we've
had this whole journey of um getting as
much data and analytics into how we're
spending our money as possible because
you've got to be able to shift you've
got to be agile all of us are dealing
with budgets that aren't as big as we
would like them to be right there's you
know realities out there in the market
right now we're we're all crunched so
you got to use the data and the
analytics to just keep optimizing and
optimizing and optimizing it's funny you
touched on something I always laugh
about when I first got into marketing 14
years ago I knew nothing about for 500
marketing I've done marketing my whole
life but and invested into platforms
that I thought would Define the future
of marketing but I hadn't been in the
game in Madison Avenue and one of my
first meetings the marketer said Gary my
budgets it's like a real problem and I
like all I felt all bad and I you know I
grew up in a family business so I like
the person was like really like you know
my but you know just like really like oh
my God my budgets and so I was like man
I felt really bad I'm like oh man and I
was like well how much budget do you
have and she was like oh my God I only
have $14 million this year I was like
$14 million I'm like I she was on she
was on a bubblegum brand I was like I
can get every human on earth to eat your
bubble gum for $14 million I think you
know sometimes Us in Big Business land
Fortune 500 land we worry about our
budgets and so many people watching
right now on streams like you know their
budget for their small business or
startup is 100,000 for the year and so I
think you can make money go a long way
obviously you have a big task you have a
very big task in getting people to
understand the modern Xerox but uh we
are heavily rooting for you and I hope
you have a great great holiday thank you
happy holidays Gary thanks for having me
of course Take
Care thank you Gary thanks for joining
us have a great afternoon all right
we'll see you soon next up we're gonna
welcome Haley Grant she leads strategy
and ADV VOR Consulting and oh my gosh
you are gorgeous Haley oh my gosh thank
you so much
we're excited we're pretty fired up to
have Aaron DWI up next and I have to
tell you she's from matter of fact I
have been using this every day and it I
was telling her that it actually makes
me feel like glowy inside and out so um
I'm I'm the new you know new biggest fan
um and I love the fact Erin that you um
so first of all uh this brand was
started by former K-pop Star Paul bike
um and and Aaron little little fun fact
was a professional dancer like previous
life all the things previous life she's
also VP she formerly VP of digital at
drunk elephant and wey so she's uh she's
cut her teeth in a pretty competitive
category so very excited to have you
join us Erin and I'll let Haley take it
away awesome thank you so much Andrea
and Erin I'm so excited to be here with
you today and hi everybody who's been
joining marketing for the now today
what'ss in store for
2024 um I'm so excited to talk to you
Ain I know there's so many things that
we want to cover today um a little bit
about me and why I'm talking to you
today with everybody is that um in vayer
Consulting we always talk about
representing the consumers in every
single room that you're in and no
industry uh has it a bigger importance
for consumers than Beauty and skin and
so as we talk a little bit about start
stop and continue I know there's like
three burning question questions that I
have for you that I would love to hear
your perspective on um we're going to
talk about consumers and a little bit
about your Discovery um your point of
view on some of the creative learnings
this year and then business um and so
true in true Vayner fashion I would love
to um start a little bit about the
consumers maybe um if you'd like to
share some like learnings and
discoveries that you've had this year
having interacted with people um
thinking about that start stop and
continue in the in the consumer bucket
yeah I think consumers is a really
interesting space because you know I'm
old and you grew up in marketing where
you kind of created these Target
audiences like primary and secondary and
you built these buckets and what's
interesting now is that might be the
person who ultimately purchases the
product but how they engage with your
content and who that audience might be
you're seeing a blurring of Boomers
making content that Gen X millennium gen
Z are watching you've got gen Z making
content that Boomers and Gen X are
watching and so there's a lot of Blurred
Lines where you used to buy T media
based on you know it's American Idol and
this is the age group and this is who
watches it but now what they watch isn't
always like what you would expect and so
there's this blurring of that um that we
have to pay attention to and there's an
importance of like figuring out your own
target audience um knowing who that
buyer is but then also figuring out
where they are um on all the different
platforms what they're watching and kind
of having an open mind of of who your
target audience is yeah absolutely even
thinking I love the idea of like the
halo effect in especially Beauty like my
mom has amazing skin so I'm like
watching the the content that's like how
do the 60-year-olds Keep Their Skin like
that so I can start now is there
anything you've seen in terms of like
the generation sort of um conspiring in
skincare oh yeah I mean we've seen that
for years years I mean I got into
skincare at a young age I was passionate
about it because I read books about skin
and learning how it's like the largest
organ and um you know you watch what
your mom does or what an aunt does or a
grandmother does and that kind of now
you've got these dual um influencers and
creators who are moms and daughters who
are making content together you're
seeing young kids get into skincare so
much sooner because of Tik Tock and
their you know Dr elephant's done
exceptionally well in that space and
they are almost more like the Beanie
Babies of our time or like tamagachi am
I totally aging myself right now right
or Pokemon which my kids are poon cards
yeah and now people are so into skin
care that it's something that they're
almost collecting and they're really
passionate about and there's also a
massive uh shift in how much people are
educated and they're asking incredible
questions because there's so much
information out there which has its pros
and cons people are walking into
Sephoras and asking really difficult
questions that we wouldn't have asked
when I was you know 18 to 24 so it's
it's definitely interesting to see um
the the evolution of knowledge as well
which really pushes the industry forward
which I think is pretty awesome yeah I
feel like that's like a really good seg
way to talk about sort of the the
business side of like thinking about
your own business and how do you just
based on your experiences and drunk
elevant and way and those things like
knowing that that's the reality um how
do you think different ly about like the
social advertising space knowing that
that's what's going on with consumers
yeah it's hard um and and you're also
kind of connected to the algorithm so
there's you might know and you could be
a luxury brand or a Prestige brand and
you might know who your consumer is but
if the content you make doesn't play to
whatever the algorithm is
currently in favor of um it won't work
and that algorithm changes constantly
and then at the same time you're dealing
with well my audience who might
eventually buy let's say they're an
elder Millennial they're 30 to 40 and so
they live on Instagram and Tik Tok but
Tik tok's heavily more genz content are
they watching that gen Z content so it's
kind of this constant dance you're
constantly in test learn deploy um I
think that there's a big shift happening
in trying to find your audience but also
in how those platforms are optimizing
for purchase now as well so with Tik Tok
stop happening and how that impacts what
you're placing there versus us as an Ami
Channel brand with Sephora so it's kind
of like a it's it's an everchanging game
which makes it exciting and fun but it's
not as easy to plan for uh as it might
have been 30 years ago when you're
building trp in like frequency by and
like thinking about creatively how you
show up in all those different platforms
and formats and like knowing that matter
of fact is like one of the most
beautiful Brands I've ever seen if you
have not been to the website guys by the
way please go because it's like I want
to buy all of it um but you are a
highend you're luxury and then just
thinking about how you show up on Tik
Tok versus
Instagram what have you learned and what
do you think you'll do more of in 2024
to sort of balance that luxury versus
how people show up it's so hard because
ugc performs traditionally exceptionally
well especially in our space people want
to see people who look like them who
don't you know look overp polished like
it's some big production but as a luxury
or Prestige brand there's Integrity to
the brand you're building that you're
trying to stay true to and it's again a
dance of we want to get the conversion
and the awareness but we want to stay
true to who we are and so I think what
we learned this year was actually ugc
didn't work as well for us as we had
anticipated however we're seeing shifts
in that again with the algorithm so now
we're like oh what we saw six months ago
now we might need to shift and it's
figuring out how you splice you know
your personality as a brand now has so
many layers like a cake so the UTC piece
how do you do that in a way that's
balanced so it doesn't degrade your
luxury your prestige but demonstrates
authenticity demonstrates to your
audiences they feel they can trust it
but also you're building your owned
content in a way that feels like a
pillar of the brand that people know
what it stands for that it's you know
not just a you know Instagram brand for
lack of a better term and that it's this
kind of you're building this and one of
the hardest parts is we don't have
Heritage so luxury brands that exist
today have Heritage and they have years
of building that heritage so as you're
building one in today's world I think
that that Playbook doesn't exist yet
because it's just starting of how do you
build luxury and prestige in a space of
Tik Tock and insta and live shopping and
keep that you know special DNA and um
Integrity yeah I love that so much it's
like start leaning into consumers but
not at the expense of your brand and
continue to look for like those moments
that you can own and help you build your
own Heritage if if I were to like try to
like piece all together on theme but
yeah definitely start um leaning in into
Community going to know who your
consumer is start message testing I'm
really kind of um excited to try AI
message testing to scale before I put
into media so instead of wasting my
money trying to figure out which works
for which audience on which platform
doing it upfront with um AI platforms
because it's much more efficient than it
we have ever had before I think that's a
really exciting thing
and then creating that layer cake
continuing to build the Heritage the
connection through community Through in
real life experiences through moments
with everybody not just the mentions and
building that piece as a an element but
as you build kind of that authenticity
on some of the platforms and it's hard
because you know I my social team's
incredible but like I'll see I'll see
content and it's like a robot talking
and I'm like ah but it's trending on Tik
Tok but does that feel on brand and it's
a constant dance of of having to make
that decision I think it's a one of the
hardest things for brand stewards today
yes you you know it's like it's not
spray and prey it's like how do you find
your authentic voice and continue to
find those connections I know we're
about out of time and because it's the
end of the year and we're all feeling
the love and I loved the flowers from
the last conversation is there anyone
that you want to give flowers to while
we're sort of thinking about
2024 I've always wanted to be on Ryan's
Roses and that never happened in my life
when I lived in La so this is so
exciting um as cheesy as this is I would
give them to my mom my mom started a
business out of necessity when I was
five and I watched her grow it and have
hard days hard nights like for 30 some
years and she didn't have a college
education at the time and she just
figured it out and I learned so much
watching her and I learned so much from
her to this day from her experiences um
that allowed me to take the risks I take
today so I'd probably give them to my
mom oh my gosh go aon's Mom that's so
amazing well you are a a business Maven
and a wonderful human and thank you for
letting us learn from you today and I
think there was one comment in the chat
that's like what does Aaron think great
skin is today so you can answer in the
chat and um just thank you so much for
all of the wisdom that you shared with
us today thank you guys all for having
me I had a great time oh that was so
good you guys I love it I'm taking my
mom on a cruise uh next week and I was I
was just yeah feeling feeling all all
gushy too so thanks thanks for the shout
out for the mamas of
course thanks everybody thank you Haley
thanks Andrea all right next I would
like to bring up Shan Walsh SVP at
Vayner media Sean how are you doing hey
Andre I'm great how are you fantastic
I'm excited uh we have next up Stephanie
dobs Brown she is the chief marketing
officer of ice and New York stocking
exchange she's responsible for the
longest list of things I'm not going to
get into all of it I'm going to let you
guys just Dive Right on in thanks for
joining
Stephanie thanks so much Andrea
Stephanie great to see you thank you for
joining us here I'm marking for the now
I think um Andrea gave a great
transition I think if I if we told
everyone as you and I were prepping if
like we told everyone that you were the
CMO of the New York Stock Exchange I
think everyone would head not and say of
course I know what that is ice and
Intercontinental Exchange I think maybe
a little bit less familiar before we get
into 2024 and what you're most excited
about would love to have you kind of
like walk us through what your remit is
at I kind of the business the the
broader business challenges you are
looking to
Sol
step Stephanie I think you're on mute
can you hear me now there we go yeah
perfect I was saying we could always you
it's always good to start with ice
because with with uh it gives context to
what the New York Stock Exchange is so
ice is Big fintech um company and we
really started in the exchange space so
the majority of our exchanges are
actually Futures exchanges we also have
equities exchanges which is the New York
Stock Exchange we have a large Data
Business uh primarily in fixed income
and then we have a large and growing
mortgage technology business and so the
question I always get is well what's the
what's the connection between all of
them and if you if you actually think
about it it does make strategically a
lot of sense we are we're really in the
business of bringing buyers and sellers
together and so regardless of what part
of the business we're talking about
whether it's futures or the New York
Stock Exchange and equities which is
quite obvious that we're bringing buyers
and sellers together if you think about
our mortgage business same thing right
anybody who's ever had a mortgage it's
all about bringing buyers and sellers
together and that's really been our
strategy and our Playbook throughout our
uh entire company's existence which uh
ice has been around for about 25 years
awesome it's really helpful framework
and I think as we think about the the
construct of this conversation today in
terms of what you're most excited about
for for 2024 Gary and Jesse kick today
off kind of talking about this Japanese
concept of misogi right and and it's
Jesse's big calendar curious and I know
we talked there's a few things that you
you have top of mind but if you had to
pick one big thing that for ice and New
York Stock Exchange specifically in 2024
that you're most excited about to dive
you and your organization into what
would that be ai ai I it's so I mean
ai's been around so long geni is so
interesting and I think it's one of
those things that it's really easy to be
scared of but it's also the
opportunities that it presents I think
both in terms of marketing and and what
we could be doing and just from a human
perspective I think it's it there's so
much opportunity scary stuff with that
comes with it but so much opportunity
with AI so how yeah can you talk about
like how you guys are you because there
are so many obviously applications of
what that can mean for a business and
and different by sector how are you all
applying that today yeah and then also
kind of what are you looking to and what
are you most excited about to apply it
into kind of how you're going to bring
your business uh you know into the into
2024 yeah so there's a few things that
we've been doing when we think about AI
so there's one obvious place that we
have focused a lot is around like what
content can we create just as marketers
that are focused on such a a Hot Topic
um and I think a lot of people are doing
that a lot of people are doing it really
well we actually just launched a Content
series that was all around we call it
artificial int Ence it's all around Ai
and art and bringing those two together
and we had thought you know for us
creating really interesting content
around this topic is really a way
through when we think about reaching
some of our audiences um and I'm really
proud of the work that the team has done
on that I mean we have gotten so much
feedback and accolades on that and I
think it's because it's just really
interesting so the content is is kind of
one y for us though in terms of using Ai
and testing it we've done a bunch of
different things around that too so so
you know we look at even like creative
production you know how can we just be a
lot more efficient in terms of we churn
out so many assets every single day so
how can we use AI just to streamline
that and make that more efficient we've
used it to um to even pressure test our
own content that we create and creative
um and sometimes it makes the work
better and sometimes you know what what
we have um we're we're actually quite
pleased with um we've used it to
understand Market sentiment we've used
it to which for the YC is actually quite
helpful because there's so much Market
sentiment um with ice not as much so
that's also been really interesting as
the different applications depending on
the topics that you're talking about y
um so we've really we've sort of dabbled
in it in in a few different ways um but
I think one of the the interesting
things that we've started to do is
asking questions even just in recruiting
process um you know I think as marketers
we always have to be thinking and about
what's coming next and being really
curious about upand cominging mediums
and
AI is such an interesting way to get
into somebody's way of thinking and
their level of curiosity and how they
approach new mediums and are they
hesitant by Nature are they
more you know are they are they more
aggressive or um uh open to sort of
diving in so it's really sort of been an
interesting way to pressure test uh
during the recruitment process it's so
interesting here you talk about that
recruitment piece and it makes so much
sense when you hear a lot of the
headlines around AI or it's going to
take all of our jobs whereas you're
actually actively looking at it as a
qualifier to hire people and to bring
people right which is actually think
that actually drives a lot with what
Gary and Gary's put a lot of content on
around that exact thing it's lesser this
fear-based AI is going to take all our
job more of an opportunity of how do we
as marketers in our field but really
broad more broadly kind of take
advantage of it right that's kind of how
you're looking at it 100 perc I mean I
is it gonna take job will it take jobs
yeah you know when you think about sort
of like any new innovation that happens
I mean you can go back computer and
that's the case yeah I think we have a
choice as you know do you do you are you
led by fear or are you led by
opportunity and and and we try and
approach it by opportunity you know I
think we can't change sort of the course
of the direction that we're going as a
society and I think it creates a lot of
opportunities now all of that being said
I think that we you know we're we're we
are a very uh cautious organization
we're in financial services and so we
are very intentional about how we use it
and we make calculated decisions around
the application of it um but you know
we've said let's let's try it and and
see it makes total sense so we have
about two minutes left if there was one
other big thing that whether whether big
exciting Innovation or really practical
kind of knowledge that marketers listen
to this call could take into especially
B2B marketers heading into 2024 what
would that be I mean look I think I
think from a tool I think LinkedIn if
you're talking B2B like you got to be on
LinkedIn in my opinion I think
year-over-year continues to work harder
and harder for us um we have we get a
ton of value out of their targeting and
their data and analytics capabilities um
and they're always churning out new
tools and and things to try and
functionality so that would be the one
thing I would say as a marketer yeah if
you're in B2B you know yeah see it's I
think it's such a great point we talk
about it all the time as underpriced
detention B2B even in B Toc right
reaching people as humans but in the
context of when they're spending time on
LinkedIn we see the same thing even
though cpms might be higher on a
comparable note what you're actually
getting and the value and the context
we're actually seeing it pan out down
the line so we're seeing the exact
things I agree and when you've got tight
budgets as Gary was talking about
earlier being really intentional and
Linkedin does that for us right we don't
have $14 million budgets potentially
necessarily right so we have to be smart
right um so I guess the last thing
before we left I'm gonna pick up on what
Gary started and what Haley started any
flowers that you would want to give out
head as we head into 2024 of of 2023 I
think that's a great so I'm GNA go I
love the shout out to to the to the mom
I'm gonna actually go the other
direction and do a shout out to my son
because I think in the same way I think
when you have to see the world through
um a kid's eyes my son is four you look
at everything differently and it sort of
allows you to really be empathetic and
compassionate and I think as marketers
that is one of if not the most important
skills that you have is is really being
empathetic to who you're trying to
communicate with so my my flower is for
my son wow well I love that Stephanie if
you had said that eight weeks ago I
would not have understood it but I had
it my first my first child seven weeks
con resonates massively and I couldn't I
couldn't have said it better myself um
so I think with that um super excited
well the last one maybe a fun Lucky
Strike extra here Stephanie as we were
kind of chatting um biggest flops in
2023 um or biggest things that maybe we
thought would have come to fruition and
maybe didn't see it's been a wild year
in a couple different ways so I didn't
know if you had any thoughts there as
well I don't know I don't know if I
would say flop I would say the I think
the sleeper tactic that is going to come
back with a with a real force is going
to be around VR AR immersive yes um I
think you know gen has really taken mind
share from from everything and sort of
sucked the air out of the room but I
think that when you start to think about
immersive experiences and whatever that
kind of looks like I think that is going
to end up really gaining traction and
momentum again so I wouldn't say it was
a flop but I think attention kind of was
diverted from that yeah um and I think
that will come back yeah it was kind of
presented or talked about as this big
Silver Bullet that was going to come and
dominate the metaverse was here and it's
kind of been a slower matriculation but
I totally agree it's especially in that
augmented reality space yeah I mean how
like just curious I mean some folks are
probably thinking well how would the New
York Stock Exchange or I how how does
that an arv or how does that even make
sense or compute like how are you all
thinking about that so we we partnered
with unity Technologies to create um an
immersive experience around the bell
ringing so we open and close uh the
markets with a with a bell ringing every
single day and often times you have to
be in the building to be able to do that
and of course Co changed everything
around that and so we worked with unity
to create um really a virtual experience
to kind of open up that that moment for
more yeah and it just got us thinking
around what else can we do especially
for the New York Stock Exchange when it
is kind of a building that you kind of
come into I mean it has a lots of
extensions around the world um but it's
it's got us thinking a lot around not
just the New York Stock Exchange
although that's more more applications
around that but certainly around how we
Market um and again I think I think as
we kind of rightsize you know the
attention around um AI I think immersive
is going to come back in a big way and I
think that they will intersect in a
really really big way 100% um it's a
really interesting application to hear
you talk about that as well for your
industry your specific you know it's a
really it's a new frontier of building
those brand connections right and it's
like and you know marketers back to your
curiosity point marketers that will win
this is our hypothesis which you know
starts with Gary and matriculates
through our organization but marketers
that are going to be curious and follow
attention and especially there when it's
underpriced or early and really figure
out are going to be able to win in scale
I think I think you're spot on I think
if if you're following attention and you
are asking questions and you're not
afraid to try things I think it was um
Dena that maybe had talked about sort of
trying new things I think sky's the
limit sky is the limit I couldn't agree
more um I think we're coming up uh up
here on time oh there we go I I sense
Andrea was coming I could feel feel your
presence Andrea you guys are amazing
thank you so much for all thanks for
having me thank you so
much all right last thank you
Sean last but not least if we can
welcome up Mary Kate McGrath Chief brand
officer from Gallery Media Group oh my
goodness hi Andrea are you live from
Miami I'm live from art bosel where we
talk about AI we have the meta and rayb
ban event going on right now right in
front of me so if I could turn my camera
around you'd see the green room and a
lot of amazing uh things happening well
we can feel the energy and thanks so
much for stepping out um we've got our
our final conversation we're so happy to
have you leading it we are going to be
welcoming up Claudine Patel who's the
chief marketing officer at
sopi and Claudine H happens to be a 25
year vet despite the fact that we we
have to get all of her beut maybe 26 now
27 I have Vlogs
count and she came from Brands like
mondes Kelloggs me Johnson and wet so so
excited to have you and I'll let you
guys take it
away thank you for joining us today you
know jealous you know Miami it's it's
nice I can tell you that it's it's nice
it's it's gonna be a good week it's
gonna be a good week what's on your mind
you know I think about when I when I
read about how start stop start and
continues started right it started out
of an idea of Bram young the idea of how
to add value to your world and you're
such a Valu Le leader what what what
does it bring to mind for you when
you're trying to add value how do you
personally look at start stop and
continue in your own
world well first of all I I think it's
it's hard right because um just because
with every time you join a new
organization or you're faced with new
challenges you try to always discard
what has worked um worked well even from
the past and the way I try to um manage
stop start and continue in my world is
especially with a lot of the recent
roles I've been in uh where I'm tasked
with probably more transform
transformative initiatives I always try
to think about
um uh stop and continue through the lens
of probably what has worked so we don't
discard all the good knowledge that has
been done right um and then I think it's
always easy to say let's start a let's
start a fresh you know I'm coming to
bring in all these new things uh into
the world that I operate in but it's
always good to see what others have done
and have been successful so that I
always look through that lens to see
what we should be continuing and then in
addition to that always tap into what
the experience of others to see what we
should be stopping what has
traditionally been OPP things we've
tried but may not have been so
successful it's okay to learn it's okay
to fail
um I actually embrace that and I always
tell uh the teams I work with to operate
with um the idea of respectful cander
where we can always debate you know so
those are things we would eventually
stop and then naturally start is you
know the world is so dynamic in
marketing that we always have to try to
make sure we're in the Forefront of um
Trends and creativity um and tools that
can create impact to the business right
so naturally in terms of starting
there's always starting with this sense
of curiosity and and instilling that
mindset across the teams and we try to
then start what we believe are new and
interesting things to build into The
Virtuous cycle of start stop continue
right so like more recently I think we
and I heard the previous um uh uh you
know speaker um speak about a lot of
things around generative AI um VR AR and
the comeback of that right the new
opportunities for immersive experience I
think though imers experiences I think
those are things we continue to um
evaluate and think about starting and
evolving um I'm I'm actually Fair
fortunate to work with a team that has a
lot of that uh Fringe Tech background as
well so we're having fun exploring new
things you know I love it I love it how
do you personally do it yourself as a
leader what what as what how do you use
that philosophy or that framework for
yourself um not just the business but
like what do you personally looking
forward to 24 yeah can you name some
some some concrete things that you are
are looking to start stop and continue
um personally uh in terms of yeah so um
you know I've I've joined copi this year
if I look and
reflect
um I think uh where I'd like
to continue is the um ability to
continue to debate um and drive a
healthy kind of respectful Kender
culture right because we we're going
through you know an you know continued
optimization I mean the the consumer
health industry is challenging it is
tough but I feel like I'm working with a
team of Fighters um you know that that
love the idea of continuing to have
really candid conversations so I believe
we're making traction I think initially
naturally being new there's been a
little bit of hesitation right to come
to a table and actually talk about talk
and debate about things that's working
not working but I feel like I've myself
and the team has embraced that spirit
and so moving into next year I think
that's one thing personally from a
values L perspective I want to make sure
we continue with the team I think where
where we want to stop is once again this
has been a hard year for us you know a
challenging year right just because of
hit wins in the industry but naturally
once again going through how do we think
about continued success moving into 24
and so what I'd like to stop is you know
eventually fear has to go away um to be
able to enable us to move faster with
more agility um with more Um passion for
taking some calculated risk so the
stopping the fear and squishing the the
fear of failure is what I would say I
would continue to encourage us and even
me to stop and then in terms of
starting um you know I'm excited once
again we're trying a lot of new things
and coming out at the stop start um I
think next year is going to be fun I'm
actually really looking forward to flip
the page in terms of more that we can do
on the business and for and within our
marketing Community once again I I I
love the idea of Fring Tech I love the
idea of thinking about leading with
design thinking and areas of we can
impact the brands and the business with
sustainability as well so a lot of these
initiatives I feel were just starting
out you know and so I'm excited to see
how we as a team from a values
perspective continue to squish fear
failure um Embrace respectful cander
because it pushes us to be better as a
team um and just continue to start to
have fun you know um figuring out new
ways to impact the business in a really
positive way I think you nailed it right
like the starting seems easy because
you're you're excited by a new idea it's
not it's a big it's a big load the
continuing is is is what we all done
we've rested on our Laurels the stopping
is sometimes really hard for your team
and it sounds like that radical cander
that you have them um experiencing and
feeling is such a lubricant to those
conversations yeah absolutely but to
your point it's it's it's not easy right
um everybody will be at different points
of the journey
um so patience is needed um but also
deliberateness is needed in terms of how
do you figure out use cases right and
our in our the language we use in our
worlds how do we figure out value based
use cases that we can make sure that
there are people within the teams that
can showcase how that is done and you
you figure out a way to um amplify that
behavior amplify that thought uh that
thinking across the organization outside
we talked about how you as a leader um
look at start St continue how you as as
a team embody that and embrace that what
would you love the marketplace to stop
doing in
2024 that's a load out question um with
all due respect and all love but just
what what what what are you excited
maybe to see less of next
year you know I have to be honest I am
not sure the reason why I say that is
I've learned so much from
brands or brands or Le or depending
right because values eventually move to
actions and then it moves to impact to
the business right and so I would say um
I've learned so much
from what I've seen to be working from a
leadership standpoint but also what I've
seen to not be working you know and
through that I actually learn of how I
can apply these lessons to myself and
the way I lead and the way I encourage
my teams to lead right so but then um
from a business standpoint I also think
just looking at I'm sure I don't know
what happens internally in in many of
these organizations but I can imagine
only how
certain um uh leads right within the
organizations um push for change but
it's not not everything is always done
right right your point about the stop
stop start continue so I've seen how
that has impacted brands in maybe
negative ways too once again I think
it's good to think about the lessons
learned and apply it back to either the
business or the way you lead right I I
think the key values once again if I
take a step back is really you can learn
from anything don't be afraid to try but
at the end of day if you lead with your
values and you lead with a s sense of
authenticity um it's going to play out
you know however which way where people
can also get lessons um from the
marketplace so I don't know I don't know
what I would I would necessarily want to
no I I hear
it yeah I think that you know it's
interesting I think it's it goes back to
what you were saying before I think that
you are somebody who sees the
opportunity and you see the um what what
lies ahead you seem to be somebody who
is a real growth mindset versus a fixed
mindset it's something that we've kind
of uh I've seen over your your post and
kind of some of the things you've
written and and been in conversations
about how do you embody your team to see
next year as all the opportunities that
you
see it's not easy you know because some
sometimes you know because uh once again
you you have you know working with teams
especially larger teams and some of
these larger organizations
everybody moves at different pace and
are different parts of um embracing
change right and so I would say that the
one thing um I've noticed to be very
helpful is in I guess in the tech world
of once again use cases I would apply
that to are there a few people you
believe that can be Champions Within in
your team to help Drive the change with
you right and then um I was just having
a conversation this morning um with um
with someone on my shopper team um Marlo
and I I I was talking I mean she came up
with a really great idea and she wanted
sometime to just kind of Bounce some of
these ideas with me and I'm like you
know why don't we um figure out a way to
uh C and she was actually thinking about
using a use case too and and working
with one of our brand leads within the
organization I'm like why don't you use
that use case and we'll find a forum for
you to um show um the team thinking
right love it how you plan to exploit
the opportunity and you know um e and
maybe even highlight some of the
challenges that you see moving ahead but
there's nothing like tangibility there's
nothing like seeing um how other people
are mobilizing them and their cross
functional teams or their teams to be
able to
drive change um and I get I get inspired
by that too because I learn from others
as well you know I'm not precious about
where the idea come from comes from and
we shouldn't be right or who wants a
champion that change if you just affect
one more person if you learn from one
more person I think that's where the
that's where the spirit really comes
alive so yeah once again you don't see
half the time I'm tired and I'm bit by
900 PM but what you do see is moments of
of what I do see is moments of Sparks
where I get really excited and I I get
energy from from others and from the
teams that I work with where else do you
get this energy from is it is it
LinkedIn is it that is that Community is
it is it uh mentors in the space is it
you know it's interesting like when you
come to different events like AR basle
and things like this where you kind of
put yourself in New Perspective oh yeah
are you are you there right now I'm here
right now hope there's not like base in
the background of this DJ but I can hear
it though oh you can oh gosh but um when
you see Big Sky and big you know um
Vistas you kind of think bigger right
it's the same thing I think that happens
in can and it happens at offsites it
happens in many different ways when you
kind of move yourself out of a the norm
you start thinking it's why holiday
rejuvenates everyone and and you come
back a little fresher and maybe a spark
of a new thing where do you find your
inspiration um the copout the copout
word everywhere C no but I'm not I'm not
going to I'm going to expand on that so
I I've I've always told people I am what
you would call an introverted extrovert
you know
um talking to people STS my energy and
actually I need to go to bed earlier so
maybe from 9:00 p.m. I'll just I'll get
it I'll go to bed by 7 right but where I
find um and but where I am extremely um
I always try to go to events I always
try to meet new people um people that
are different or bring diverse thinking
to how I've traditionally saw things
excite me and it actually gives me the
energy so I would say it comes from
everywhere especially with people that
comes to the table with different
opinions um that I can actually learn
from um so for me I feel like I always
try to go out there you know um and and
I actually told uh someone that I work
with as well right once again I go back
to learning um and sourcing ideas from
everywhere uh it was someone actually
within my team and he was like okay you
know he always jokes like okay this is
Korea Swiss suicide right but I'm like I
love it I love debating because I
actually learned from you and I I think
you push me to think a little bit
differently and I may be wrong who all
the time right so that's where that's
where I actually believe uh people with
Divergent backgrounds and diver and
diverse thinking and thought leadership
can actually challenge you to be better
and that's where I always try to Source
or get meet people to to get that those
different experiences Gary VE for
example right I mean like he's you know
he's sometimes I'm like what are you
saying dude but like I'm like but but
that but I mean I learned from him too
because his thinking is so Divergent
that he comes with multiple different
perspectives that sometimes you do you
don't I know I know I mean Gary is in it
his own other world but what I will say
about Gary is one of the things I love
about him the most and there are many is
when you're at a table with Gary and you
have a different opinion he takes as an
invitation to start an incredible
discourse he has enough people agreeing
with him it's the it's the moment I
think you're right I think for marketing
and for the marketers like ourselves
like we have to consistently we have to
look for the new right we have to be
there early and often so if we're not
there if we're not really welcoming in a
different perspective all of the time um
I think that that's where we we lose
sight I think that's my start for next
year too I think that's like put myself
in in very strange and new places
absolutely because I think you know
listen I I I am a big de and Champion I
think we you know we want to make sure
we build an inclusive culture right but
inclusivity and in conversations we
always forget that inclusivity is also a
mindset right and so outside of making
sure we encourage we uh bringing
different people to the table I think
the one thing we need to also realize is
we need to bring different thinking and
mindsets to the table right and I think
for that I I'm actually a big champion
of um and I can get enough of it you
know um because to be honest with you
I'm not that smart um where I've been
fortunate enough is to work with people
that are and it has allowed me to
continue to learn from experiences and
to just be better you know and so I
think we think you are very smart and we
are very impressed and um I'm sad to see
Andre here because it's I could talk to
you all day but thank you so much and we
would love it I I tend to agree I think
that's where we have to draw the line
Claudine you incredibly smart and I
think we should go and pack our bags
right now and meet Mary Kate at
the Bas what do you say give me give me
four hours or maybe three hours I think
from Chicago to there it's like two and
a half three hours so I'll see you okay
well we'll see you there thanks you two
this was a phenomenal wave and our 2023
marketing for the now with such heart
thanks to you both love it thank you so
much thank
you and thank you to all of our viewers
uh we we just so enjoy these times of
gathering up um we're going to another
show in 2024 on
January uh the 18th and it's going to be
from 12:30 to 1:30 eastern time and
until then please feel free to go back
we record all of these episodes as well
U feel free to go back and check them
out on YouTube we get a 100,000 views
every time and we can't thank you guys
enough for all of your support and we
will see you in January of 2024 thanks
everybody